matthew boyd on the mound tonight for
the tigers you can see his record he
would like to get back to 500 and then
work from there not hitting jp crawford
will lead things off for the mariners
he's been outstanding and boy the big
left-hander is ready here's the wind-up
first pitch of the game swinging a line
shot diving triad short goodrum off his
glove the ball trickles into left field
and here's mitch
that dude's bad he's nationwide pops it
up on the infield
jonathan scope takes control went away
now he's got to deal with two runners on
runner and scoring position down in
second base guy that's really done some
damage against the tigers this guy it
seems like when he does make contact he
gets extra base hits the 1-0
lifts it to left field
shallow left
out and third base goes paredes and he
makes the play
and the mariners leave two against
matthew boyd they'll be facing off
against veteran lefty marco gonzalez
back up on the mound for the second time
since coming off the injured list first
inning our home straight bank score the
baron is nothing and the tigers coming
up to face veteran left-hander marco
gonzalez
rip to left staffer into the corner
grossman able to reset button
and cruising in with a leadoff double
maybe that day off
did robbie grossman well one away from
miguel cabrera playing in game number 2
500
in his career tonight
the 2-2
driven a right
that's down
into the right field corner that'll
drive in grossman and miguel cabrera's
got an rbi in the first and the tigers
lead at one nothing
he stays back enough and shoots it hard
down the right field line so that was a
great piece of hitting there
no problem at all for robbie grossman to
get around and score on that one
matthew boyd getting through that first
inning with a little traffic and now he
has a one run lead to work with
stripes one the deep left field get out
of here he's done it again
he's unreal he's on point it's a two-run
blast three-nothing tigers
i'll tell you what
this kid
is more than hitterish
he's a hitter period castro the batter
now one out
what a leaping catch j.p crawford didn't
even have time to blink two outs
here's esau paredes
[Applause]
crawford
on to first
out number three three runs coming for
the tigers highlighted by the two-run
smash from eric haas
now man the third two outs brings up
donovan walton
pitch number seven to walton
in play bobbled by scope and the
mariners get a run out of it
the scope and error here and this is the
ball that i don't know if he kind of let
it play him or what but he never
got it in his glove as he swipes at it
it just points out of his glove
to the left scope joining good room
paredes on the left side of the infield
3-1 tigers in the second the pitch swing
the line drive down the left field line
that's trouble but do on the run reaches
out he made the catch wow
didn't think he had a chance and after
miss playing the first ball of the
inning akil badu just made one of the
best running catches you will see tigers
half of the second they're up 3-1 it'll
be nico goodroom akil badu and derrick
hill
broken that looper into center and
that's going to drop
sometimes it's not how hard you hit it's
where you hit it and that one worked out
well you'll take it right positive
mindset for him
because aj told him when he came up look
you're going to play for a while there
goes goodrum and murphy no throw
kind of
gets in a bad rut he doesn't give him
that second look he can gets a great
secondary lead and he's taking it
made him feel like okay i can start
there's a base hit to left an rbi single
for derrick hill he's gonna dig for two
it was bobbled in left field and he
burned him with a head first slide into
second
the first base coach lets him know take
a look out there right
he rounds first
he sees that
donovan walton bobbles the ball and he
knows he's got enough speed to scatter
down there
you get an extra 90 feet and put
yourself in scoring position just
because of good hustle jonathan scope
has been so dialed in it's been
refreshing to watch him hit over the
last 24 games or so but scope does like
to pull the ball with two strikes a
little different the o2 right up the
middle
hill should score easily with his speed
he does without a throw jonathan scope
comes through
you want an add-on run you've got a nail
on run thing you don't want to do is
pull off this baseball with two strikes
and scope stays on this ball and hits it
well enough to where he gets it right
back up the middle to driving another
add-on run here
well matthew boyd takes them out in the
sixth inning it's been an interesting
outing yes it has
first trip to the lineup hard contact
one run second trip to the lineup
i would say even more hard contact
swinging a high fly ball left center
field but due
will go a few steps to his left back to
his right make the easy catch one pitch
went up
now the one-two
eyeball to center field
derrick hill's got it he's been a busy
man in center field two away
i think this is big if he it's jack
mayfield he's did a fly ball to center
and hit a harder fly ball to center what
lifts that right leg good turn drives to
home plate the 2-2 swing and a miss
change-up got him to chase
and if that's the end of the night for
matthew boyd and it likely is that's a
heck of a finish just love it fantastic
matthew jake fraley at the plate and
he's hit a couple of big home runs since
coming off the injured list here's the
stretch next off around the way swinging
a check swing back toward the mound gets
on by the pitcher charging the shortstop
good room his throw to first not in time
fraley is safe at first and the mariners
have the bases loaded with nobody out
here in the top of the eighth inning
long doubled and scored in the second
then a couple of fly balls to aquila
doing left
[Music]
on the ground scope to second on to
first base it is in time for the double
play france scores
the mariners get one run but give up two
outs
and scott wants to see if maybe
shed was able to lay that out live two
tigers taylor trammell stands in against
daniel norris with two outs and a runner
at third
the 1-0
driven to right center field
that's going to get up the gap another
run trots home
tremel
into second base an rbi double for the
mariner center fielder and it's 5-3
detroit jose cisnero as we mentioned
converted the save his first of his
major league career on saturday cisnero
deals with jp crawford he's been on base
four times tonight
here's the o2
and he got him looking
he didn't like the one before how about
that one kid
and out of the way he's got to get ty
france
[Applause]
fly ball center field derrick hills got
it and the tigers win it 5-3
their first
season series win over seattle since
2016